taliban forces in afghanistan have been
battling to capture the only province
not under their control pangaea
elements of the afghan army and fighters
loyal to former vice president abdullah
saleh have assembled in the panchayat
valley which is surrounded by mountains
making it difficult to capture despite
this a taliban spokesperson has claimed
that the area has fallen though this
hasn't been independently confirmed
let's get more from journalist france
marty in kabul welcome france and what
are you hearing about these taliban
claims of victory in the pangaea
there has been no official taliban claim
that they have taken panch here
but
a propagandist very close to the taliban
has claimed that as well as other
accounts uh to fair verify this is
difficult because telephones don't seem
to work at the moment in panchayat or at
least all my calls didn't went through
um shortly afterwards uh
uh sent a video message to uh tv
stations in which he said he's still in
punch here and that they that there's
fighting going on but that they are
resisting so there has been fighting
there has been advantages what exactly
happened is unclear um it seems that the
taliban in kampun thought uh that pancho
is um
uh conquered uh because there has been
like celebratory gunfire all over the
city which was reportedly uh because
they thought the province has fell but
again hasn't been confirmed as of yet
and how important is it
to the taliban to take pangaea
on the one hand it is the the last
pocket of organized resistance so it is
kind of a beacon of hope for for
anti-taliban forces um on the other hand
it also depends a lot on how the taliban
would like defeat
uh punch here if it is very bloody it
could like spark
resistance movements in other parts of
the country so that's also why the
taliban tried to to have a
surrendered um solution uh but this
hasn't yielded any results so far um so
the taliban want to control the the
whole country and of course if there is
like resistance um it doesn't make them
look good and the questions there um
their claim to rule all of afghanistan
right and today today the taliban were
supposed to reveal afghanistan's new
government but this hasn't happened what
has been the hold up
first of all the taliban haven't like
clearly announced when they will
reveal their new regime it has been
expected that it might happen today but
this was never that clearly announced um
it will likely happen in the next few
days uh
one reason that uh was holding it up uh
was probably that american forces were
still present that the taliban wanted to
wait until all american forces
left the country which happened on 30th
of august what is now the delay is is
not exactly clear but for example um
certain almost uh that the majority of
the main taliban leaders haven't yet
revealed themselves in public it's
unclear where they are so maybe this is
also to do with the hold up until they
are here or in kandahar or wherever they
will announce their new government okay
thank you for that franz marty in kabul
meanwhile a small group of women have
been protesting in kabul demanding equal
rights under taliban rule it was the
second women's protest in as many days
on thursday women gathered in herat
calling for access to education and jobs
the taliban have promised to respect
women's rights but within their
interpretation of islamic law
freedom
independence a voice
these women marching through kabul
refused to give up these things under
taliban rule they are demanding women's
participation in the taliban's new
government their slogan a society in
which women are not active is a dead
society
over the last 20 years we women have
taken part in all aspects of life side
by side with the men so no one can
exclude us we should not be ignored we
ask the islamic emirate of afghanistan
and all the international community
especially women from other countries
around the world to support
we must have a us
in decision making in the policy
the education is a job and everyone must
be arrested they cannot be silent at
home after the government established
they will not trust us they will not
allow us to come
and they will be the same taliban as 20
years ago
we cannot trust them
a protest like this would have been
unimaginable the last time the taliban
were in power
back then women were ordered to wear
burqas covering the entire body with a
mesh fabric window to see through they
were not allowed to leave home alone if
they defied the strict sharia rules they
were beaten or stoned
north of kabul on this market in the
city of maasai sharif merchants say
burka sales have gone up since the
taliban took power
under the previous government i wore a
hijab or other appropriate dress
but now i want a new burka
because after the takeover by the
taliban they said that women should
observe the veil
if women are not an active part of
society western nations have threatened
to cut aid to afghanistan the taliban
pledged to respect women's rights but
within the framework of islam without
specifying what exactly they mean by
that
[Music]
well european union officials have been
meeting in slovenia to discuss how best
to deal with the taliban foreign
ministers from the 27 member states have
announced their conditions for
engagement with the incoming government
in in afghanistan
eu authorities evacuated the country
after the taliban takeover last month
but have signaled a will to re-establish
relations if the new rulers meet certain
criteria
these include the taliban respecting
human rights and cracking down on terror
groups which want to use the country as
a base now germany's foreign minister
heiko mass says the eu will only start
sending aid
if the taliban make good on their
promises
they've made many moderate remarks in
recent days but we do not want to
measure the taliban and this new
government by their words but rather by
their actions
whether we resume sending aid that's a
question which will be decided by their
actions in afghanistan